rare moment de répit pour ces infirmiers
d'un hôpital de montevideo sur les
quinze derniers jours
l'uruguay a enregistré près de 1400 cas
pour 100000 habitants soit l'un des taux
d'infection les plus élevés au monde
infirmiers et médecins sont à bout c'est
une situation très fatigante et les gens
qui m'entourent le savent être ici toute
la journée est très pesant vous voyez
des choses que vous devez oublier
lorsque vous partez ici parce que la
saison et voire koné 1 et les tas de
gens me disent que c'est bien une
explosion des cas qui s'explique par sa
frontière terrestre avec le brésil
restées ouvertes dans quelques villes
transfrontalière et par laquelle est
entrée le variant brésilien réputé plus
contagieux ils représentent aujourd'hui
plus de 60% des cas positifs en uruguay
des uruguayens jusqu'alors épargnée par
le virus
donc moins conscients du danger dans les
rues de la capitale montevideo
la vie est presque normal peu
d'habitants portent le masque les
espaces publics restaurants bars et
marchés sont restés ouverts
le gouvernement ne limitant les
restrictions qu'à la fermeture des
services publics des écoles et salles de
sport couverte une volonté du président
uruguayen luis lacalle époux ne voulant
surtout pas entraver ceux qui sortent
chaque jour pour gagner leur pain mais
un médecin dénonce le manque de prise de
conscience
je pense que les gens ne croient pas au
virus c'est juste qu'ils n'y croient pas
à un moment donné nous pensions qu'ils y
croyaient et maintenant je pense que je
n'y crois pas on le voit dans la rue
presque tout le monde sans masquer les
gens ne croient pas c'est tout tant que
vous n'avez pas un parent ici vous ne
croyez pas en 2020 la gestion du
gouvernement du président conservateur
avait été salué suite à la fermeture
rapide de ses frontières à la fermeture
des écoles est un efficace système testé
tracé isolé
le tout sans avoir recours au
confinement obligatoire ni au couvre-feu
mais face à la dégradation rapide de la
situation
les appelle à durcir les restrictions
émergent de toutes parts selon un récent
sondage près de trois uruguayens sur
quatre ils sont désormais favorables
le gouvernement lui mise avant tout sur
la campagne de vaccination débutée le
1er mars dernier selon les derniers
chiffres 29% de la population a reçu une
dose et 7% est totalement vacciner